On the 23rd of July 2008, young mother Helen Munnings disappeared from the port city of Burney on the northwest coast of Tasmania, Australia. She was last seen by the father of her child, Adam Taylor, who picked her up for a drive that afternoon. His actions later that night were described as interesting. Extensive searches have been conducted but no trace of Helen has ever been found. A few different theories were raised that the coronial inquest held into the case. Did Helen run away? Did she commit suicide? Or was she murdered? Helen Munnings was born on the 15th of March 1988. Little is known about Helen's father,
2008年7月23日，年轻母亲海伦·曼宁斯（Helen Munnings）在澳大利亚塔斯马尼亚州西北海岸的港口城市伯尔尼（Burney）失踪。她最后一次被看到是她孩子的父亲亚当·泰勒（Adam Taylor）接她去兜风的那天下午。他当晚晚些时候的行为被形容为耐人寻味。各方进行了广泛搜寻，但至今未找到海伦的踪迹。针对此案举行的验尸聆讯提出了几种不同的理论。海伦是离家出走吗？她是自杀吗？还是被谋杀？海伦·曼宁斯于1988年3月15日出生。人们对海伦的父亲知之甚少，
she had no contact with him during her life. She was raised by her mother Carol Munnings. Helen has an older brother Mark and two younger sisters Linda and Catherine. Helen lived in Burney her entire life. Burney is a port city on the northwest coast of Tasmania. It has a population of about 20,000 people. The Burney port along with the forestry industry provide the main source of revenue for the city. It is Tasmania's largest general cargo port. In 2004 Helen met Adam Taylor. Helen was 16 at the time and Adam was 30. They had a sexual encounter the night they met. Adam tried to pass off the blame for this encounter by saying he was heavily affected by alcohol and it was Helen who came onto him. He really
她一生中与他没有任何联系。她由母亲卡罗尔·曼宁斯（Carol Munnings）抚养长大。海伦有一个哥哥马克（Mark）和两个妹妹琳达（Linda）和凯瑟琳（Catherine）。海伦一生都住在伯尔尼。伯尔尼是塔斯马尼亚州西北海岸的一个港口城市，人口约有2万人。伯尔尼港连同林业一起，是该市的主要收入来源。它是塔斯马尼亚州最大的综合散货港。2004年，海伦结识了亚当·泰勒。当时海伦16岁，亚当30岁。他们相遇的那晚发生了性关系。亚当试图为这次相遇开脱，称自己当时严重受酒精影响，是海伦主动投怀送抱的。他真的
didn't know what he was doing or couldn't even remember really what happened. Helen instantly fell in love with Adam and thought of him as her soulmate. They remained friends after this initial encounter but when Helen turned 17 Adam says she started pressuring him to commence a full blown relationship. Adam says he only agreed to a sexual relationship with Helen because she threatened to go to the police about their initial encounter when she was only 16. Adam says you were scared so he agreed to Helen's wishes. The age of consent in Tasmania is 17 years of age. Not long after Helen fell pregnant and in 2006 she gave birth to her son Tom. Tom is not her son's real name that has been changed for this story.
不知道自己在做什么，甚至记不清到底发生了什么。海伦瞬间爱上了亚当，并把他视为自己的灵魂伴侣。初次相遇后，他们保持着朋友关系，但当海伦年满17岁时，亚当称她开始施压，要求确立一段正式的恋爱关系。亚当说，他只同意与海伦保持性关系，因为她威胁说要就他们最初发生性关系（当时她才16岁）一事报警。亚当说由于害怕，所以同意了海伦的要求。塔斯马尼亚州的法定性同意年龄是17岁。不久之后，海伦怀孕了，并于2006年生下了儿子汤姆（Tom）。汤姆不是她儿子真正的名字，为了这个故事进行了更改。
Helen was 18 years old at the time. Adam was 32. Adam at first denied that he was the father but a paternity test said otherwise. This presented a problem for Adam. He was already in a long-term de facto relationship with his partner Carolina and they had two children together. He told Carolina that Tom had been conceived with Helen whilst they were on a break in their relationship. A man who had a child with missing Bernie woman Helen Munnings has told an inquest she blackmailed him into having sex. Adam Taylor admitted first having sex with Ms Munnings when she was 16 years old. Helen Munnings disappeared in July 2008 when she was 20 years old.
当时海伦18岁，亚当32岁。亚当起初否认自己是父亲，但亲子鉴定结果却表明并非如此。这给亚当带来了麻烦。他当时已经和伴侣卡罗琳娜（Carolina）保持着长期的事实婚姻关系，两人育有两名子女。他告诉卡罗琳娜，汤姆是在他和海伦感情出现间隙期间怀上的。一名与失踪的伯尔尼女子海伦·曼宁斯育有一子的男子在聆讯中作证称，海伦勒索他与其发生性关系。亚当·泰勒承认，他第一次与曼宁斯女士发生性关系时，对方年仅16岁。海伦·曼宁斯于2008年7月失踪，当时她20岁。
She had a two year old son with Adam Taylor, a man 15 years her senior. The inquest has heard about Mr Taylor's sexual history with Ms Munnings. Mr Taylor told the court he had sex with her once before she was 17 and then about a dozen times between 2004 and 2007. Mr Taylor said after Ms Munnings 17th birthday she threatened to tell police about their sexual encounter when she was underage if he didn't leave his partner. When she turned 17 that's when she started getting all crazy about it. Mr Taylor said he slept with Ms Munnings after that to keep her happy because he was scared he'd go to jail for having sex with a minor. The counsel assisting the coroner Simon Brown asked Mr Taylor you had sex with her because you were scared? Mr Taylor replied yes. Mr Taylor
她与大她15岁的亚当·泰勒育有一个两岁的儿子。聆讯听取了关于泰勒先生与曼宁斯女士性关系的陈述。泰勒先生对法庭表示，在曼宁斯女士满17岁之前，他与她发生过一次性关系，在2004年至2007年期间又大约发生了十几次。泰勒先生说，在曼宁斯女士17岁生日之后，如果他不离开伴侣，她就威胁要报警，揭发他们未成年时的性行为。当她满17岁时，她就开始为此变得非常疯狂。泰勒先生说，此后他与曼宁斯女士发生性关系是为了让她高兴，因为他害怕自己会因与未成年人发生性关系而入狱。协助验尸官的法律顾问西蒙·布朗（Simon Brown）问泰勒先生：“你和她发生性关系是因为害怕吗？”泰勒先生回答：“是的。”泰勒先生
said he was not attracted to Ms Munnings and had contemplated suicide after sleeping with her. He said Ms Munnings had also threatened to harm his partner who was pregnant to Mr Taylor. Given they now had a son together the relationship between Helen and Adam had to continue on some level. Carolina was of the understanding that there would be no ongoing physical relationship between them and they would only remain in contact over issues concerning Tom. But the evidence suggests Adam lied to Carolina and continued his relationship with Helen. Adam described Helen's behaviour towards him as at times demeaning, unpredictable, aggressive and antagonistic. Helen constantly sent text messages and made
表示，他对曼宁斯女士没有吸引力，并在与她发生性关系后考虑过自杀。他说，曼宁斯女士还威胁要伤害他的伴侣，当时对方正怀着泰勒先生的孩子。鉴于他们现在有了一个共同的儿子，海伦和亚当之间的关系不得不维持在某种程度上。卡罗琳娜的理解是，他们之间不会再有持续的身体关系，而且他们只会就涉及汤姆的问题保持联系。但证据表明，亚当欺骗了卡罗琳娜，并继续与海伦保持关系。亚当将海伦对他的行为形容为有时贬低、不可预测、咄咄逼人和充满敌意。海伦不断向亚当发送短信并拨打
phone calls to Adam about Tom. This obviously created difficulties in Adam's long-term relationship with Carolina. There were already difficulties due to what had happened but now Helen wasn't making it any easier. It led to a deal being made whereby all contact from Helen was to be sent to Adam's mother Judy Taylor. Carolina was of the belief that there would be no personal contact between Adam and Helen at all. But despite professing his wish to maintain his relationship with Carolina he continued his relationship with Helen. He took active steps to try and keep it quiet such as buying a second phone. Adam tried to deny that he maintained an intimate relationship with Helen but text messages between them revealed otherwise.
关于汤姆的电话。这显然给亚当与卡罗琳娜的长期关系带来了困难。由于之前发生的事情，关系中已经存在困难，而现在海伦让情况变得更加复杂。这导致双方达成了一项协议：海伦的所有联系都必须发给亚当的母亲朱迪·泰勒（Judy Taylor）。卡罗琳娜坚信亚当和海伦之间不会再有任何个人接触。但尽管他信誓旦旦地表示希望维持与卡罗琳娜的关系，他却依然继续着与海伦的关系。他积极采取措施试图保密，例如购买了第二部手机。亚当试图否认自己与海伦保持着亲密关系，但他们之间的短信记录却揭示了事实并非如此。
Carol Munnings, Helen's mother, strongly disapproved of Adam Taylor, her main concern being the big age difference between them. But she had concerns about Adam's treatment of Helen and his motives for continuing the relationship. She did everything in her power to prevent the relationship from continuing. She made several complaints to the police, adamant that Adam had broken the law. Helen Munnings mother Carol has been representing her family in court. During her questioning of Mr Taylor Ms Munnings made heated accusations about him controlling her daughter. She said you were the cause of Helen's problems, you were the adult, Helen was the child. Mr Taylor said Carol Munnings had made threats and allegations against him over the years they'd known each other.
海伦的母亲卡罗尔·曼宁斯强烈反对亚当·泰勒，她最担心的两人之间巨大的年龄差距。但她也对亚当对待海伦的方式以及他继续这段关系的动机感到担忧。她竭尽全力阻止这段关系的延续。她向警方多次报案，坚信亚当违反了法律。海伦·曼宁斯的母亲卡罗尔一直在法庭上代表她的家庭。在对泰勒先生进行质问期间，曼宁斯女士对他就控制她的女儿提出了激烈的指控。她说：“你是一切问题的根源，你是成年人，海伦是个孩子。”泰勒先生说，在他们相识的这些年里，卡罗尔·曼宁斯曾对他发出过威胁和指控。
But Helen only had eyes for Adam and Carol's actions were the cause of some conflict between them. They had numerous arguments and had actually got so bad that at one point they each had restraining orders out against each other. At the time of her disappearance Helen was living in a block of units owned by her mother Carol in Bernie. Helen lived in unit three and Carol lived upstairs in unit one. Helen and Tom had only been living there for a few weeks having stayed at various other places prior to that. Tom was being cared for on a split week by week basis. Helen would have him for one week then Adam would have him for the following week and so on. Helen owned a car but didn't have a driver's license so she usually walked wherever she wanted
但海伦眼中只有亚当，卡罗尔的行为成为了他们之间一些冲突的导火索。他们有过无数次争吵，甚至恶化到一度互相申请了人身禁止令。失踪时，海伦住在伯尔尼由她母亲卡罗尔名下的一栋公寓楼里。海伦住在3号单元，卡罗尔住在楼上的1号单元。海伦和汤姆搬到那里才几周，在此之前他们曾寄宿在各种其他地方。汤姆由他们按周轮流照顾。海伦带一周，然后亚当接过去带一周，如此循环。海伦有一辆车，但没有驾照，所以她要去哪里通常都是步行
to go or relied on lifts by family and friends. On the 8th of July 2008 only a few weeks before she disappeared Helen dropped the bombshell on Adam. She told him she was pregnant again. Together they went to a local pharmacy in Bernie where Helen purchased a pregnancy test. She took the test and then showed Adam the result. Adam strongly denies he was the father and says Helen told him that she was pregnant as a result of a drunk and one night stand with a male that she didn't name. But Helen's friends and family said there was nobody else that Helen had eyes for and that Adam definitely would have been the father. The coroner later found Adam's story about the drunk and one night stand with an unnamed male
或者依靠家人和朋友开车接送。2008年7月8日，也就是她失踪前几周，海伦向亚当抛出一个重磅炸弹。她告诉他自己又怀孕了。他们一起去了伯尔尼的一家本地药店，海伦在那里买了一支验孕棒。她进行了测试，然后把结果给亚当看。亚当坚决否认自己是父亲，并称海伦告诉他，怀孕是因为她和一个她没有说出名字的男子酒后发生了一夜情。但海伦的朋友和家人表示，海伦眼中没有别人，亚当绝对是孩子的父亲。验尸官后来发现亚当关于与未命名男子酒后一夜情的说法
to be untrue and said he was most likely the father. After initially being anxious and uncertain about the second child Helen made the decision to keep it. Adam didn't support this. The reason he gave was that a second child would place additional demands on Helen's already tight financial situation and it would compromise her ability to adequately look after Tom. That's the reason he says he was against it but it's doubtful there would have been a way to keep it quiet that Helen was pregnant. Even if he wasn't the father as he claims Helen was going to name him the father. This wouldn't be good news. Remember his mother and his current partner Carolina were of the belief Adam wasn't even speaking to Helen on the phone at this point.
并不属实，并表示他极有可能是孩子的父亲。在最初对第二个孩子的到来感到焦虑和不确定后，海伦决定把孩子生下来。亚当并不支持这一点。他给出的理由是，第二个孩子会给海伦本已紧张的财务状况增加额外的负担，并会危及她充分照顾汤姆的能力。这就是他说自己反对的原因，但怀疑当时有什么办法能对海伦怀孕一事保密。即使他如其所说并非父亲，海伦也会把登记他为孩子的父亲。这绝不是什么好消息。别忘了，他的母亲和现任伴侣卡罗琳娜当时都深信，亚当在这个时候连电话都没有和海伦打过。
On Wednesday the 23rd of July 2008 Helen spent her day at home. Most of her time was actually spent up in Carol's unit. Tom was in the care of Adam at the time. In the early to mid afternoon that day Helen left and walked into the center of town. She left the keys to her unit with Carol and she didn't take a handbag with her either. She left that in her unit. Her handbag contained her mobile phone, her purse and her medication. Her purse contained her bank cards and her Medicare card. Her mobile phone was left at home but the SIM card had been removed. Due to problems she was having with her phone it was common for Helen to remove her SIM card and use other people's phones. When she left the unit Helen told Carol that she had a doctor's appointment.
2008年7月23日星期三，海伦一整天都待在家里。她的大部分时间其实都是在卡罗尔的公寓里度过的。当时汤姆正由亚当照看。那天下午早些时候到中段，海伦离开家，步行去了市中心。她把公寓钥匙留给了卡罗尔，也没有随身携带手提包，而是把它留在了公寓里。她的手提包里有她的手机、钱包和药物。她的钱包里有银行卡和医疗保险卡。她的手机留在了家里，但SIM卡被取走了。由于手机出现故障，海伦经常取出SIM卡并使用别人的手机。离开公寓时，海伦告诉卡罗尔她有个预约医生。
But checks with the medical center revealed that she didn't have an appointment. She also left her Medicare card at home. She didn't go to the medical center at all. Instead she met up with Adam Taylor. Adam had been at work all day and arrived home at about 2.45pm. Tom was at home being cared for by his partner Carolina. When he arrived home he swapped cars. He left his car at home and got into his mother's holding ute. He left home about 3.30pm. Carolina says she thinks Adam put a saw into the rear of his ute before he left. Adam says he and Helen had arranged to meet up during the day. He picked her up in his mother's ute near the Centrelink building about 4.20pm. This was
但向医疗中心查询后发现，她并没有预约。她还将医疗保险卡留在了家里。她根本没有去医疗中心。相反，她去见了亚当·泰勒。亚当一整天都在上班，大约下午2点45分到家。汤姆当时在家由他的伴侣卡罗琳娜照看。到家后他换了车。他把自己的车留在家里，坐上了他母亲的霍顿皮卡。他大约下午3点30分离开家。卡罗琳娜说她认为亚当在离开前把一把锯子放进了皮卡车的后备箱。亚当说他和海伦约定好白天见面。他大约下午4点20分在Centrelink大楼附近用他母亲的皮卡接了她。这
actually captured on security camera footage so it could be verified. But as for what happened next we only have Adam's version. He says they went for a drive and talked for a while. They drove around until about 6pm. During the trip he says that he and Helen talked about matters concerning their relationship that were distressing for Helen. He says Helen became upset and started crying. However by the time he dropped her off he says she appeared to have calmed down. Helen mostly talked about her pregnancy and said she didn't want to have an abortion. After they were finished Adam says he dropped Helen off on the southern side of the Bass Highway in Burnie near the Old Papermill. He says he dropped Helen off here as she said she wanted
实际上被监控摄像头拍摄了下来，因此可以得到证实。但至于接下来发生了什么，我们只有亚当的说法。他说他们去兜风并聊了一会儿。他们开车兜风直到大约下午6点。在行程中，他说他和海伦谈论了有关他们关系的、让海伦感到痛苦的事情。他说海伦情绪变得激动并开始哭泣。不过，当他放下她时，他说她看起来已经平静下来了。海伦主要谈到了她的怀孕，并说她不想流产。事情结束后，亚当说他在伯尔尼巴斯公路（Bass Highway）南侧、老造纸厂（Old Papermill）附近放海伦下车。他说他把海伦放在这里，因为她说她想
to go for a walk along the beach to clear her head. The coroner later made comment at the inquest that this was an unusual thing to do. Drop a young girl off at that location when it was getting dark. And it was some distance away from her home. It was roughly just over a 20 minute walk. After dropping Helen off Adam says he headed home which was about a 10 minute drive away from that location. But before getting home he pulled over to have a think about what he and Helen had just discussed. He then sent a text message to Helen. The message was sent at 6.08pm. The message said keep your chin up. There was no response but remember Helen didn't have a phone with her. She just had a SIM card. Adam returned home shortly after sending the text
去海滩散步以清醒一下头脑。验尸官后来在聆讯中发表评论称，这是一种不同寻常的做法。把一个年轻女孩在天黑的时候放在那个地点。而且那里离她的家有一段距离。步行大约需要20分钟多一点。放下海伦后，亚当说他开车回家，车程离那个地点大约10分钟。但在到家之前，他和海伦刚讨论过的事情，于是他把车停在路边思考了一会儿。然后他给海伦发了一条短信。短信是在晚上6点08分发送的。信息内容是“振作点”。没有任何回复，但请记住海伦身上没有手机，她只有一个SIM卡。亚当发完短信后不久便回家了
message to Helen. When he got home he commented that he thought someone had tried to steal the small boat that they kept in their yard. The boat belonged to Caroline's brother. Adam said somebody had dragged the boat from the yard where it is usually kept down to the water's edge. He told Caroline that he was going down to drag the boat back up. But he first put it in the water, started motor up and drove it out a short distance before turning around and bringing it back in. By now it was dark. Adam then spent some time out in his back shed. But Caroline said that wasn't unusual and he would often do that at night on. The water's edge that Adam lived on at the time was actually the Bass Strait. The large stretch of ocean that separates Tasmania from the rest
。他到家后提到，他觉得有人试图偷走他们院子里放着的小船。这条船属于卡罗琳娜的兄弟。亚当说有人把船从通常存放的院子里拖到了水边。他告诉卡罗琳娜他要下去把船拉回来。但他先是把它放入水中，发动马达开出了一小段距离，然后掉头把它开回岸边。此时天已经黑了。随后亚当在后面的棚子里待了一会儿。但卡罗琳娜说这并不罕见，他晚上经常这样做。当时亚当居住的水边实际上是巴斯海峡（Bass Strait），
of Australia. That next morning Adam loaded the boat onto a trailer and took it back to Caroline's brother's house. Carol became concerned as the evening went on that Helen hadn't returned home. She used Helen's keys to let herself into Helen's unit but there was no sign of her. Carol remained worried but when Helen didn't come back the next day the worry turned into full blame panic. That next day the 24th of July just after lunch Carol reported her concern to the police and when Helen still hadn't returned home by that night Carol went back to the police station to make a formal statement. Helen was scheduled to pick Tom up on Friday the 25th of July but she failed to turn up. On the 28th and 29th of July police commenced a sea land and air search.
那是将塔斯马尼亚与澳大利亚其他地区隔开的广阔海洋。第二天早上，亚当把船装上拖车，送回了卡罗琳娜兄弟的家。随着夜幕降临，海伦仍未回家，卡罗尔开始感到担忧。她用海伦的钥匙进入海伦的公寓，但里面没有她的踪影。卡罗尔依然忧心忡忡，但当海伦第二天还没有回来时，担忧变成了彻底的恐慌。第二天7月24日刚过午饭时间，卡罗尔就向警方报告了她的担忧；当晚海伦仍未返回时，卡罗尔再次前往警察局做正式笔录。海伦原定于7月25日星期五接汤姆，但她没有出现。7月28日和29日，警方展开了海、陆、空联合大搜寻。
The searching area was expanded the next month. A helicopter, divers and a ground search crew were used. Despite an extensive search no trace of Helen was ever found. The information about Adam's movements with the boat the night Helen disappeared didn't become known until sometime much later and the search of the ocean outside his home wasn't done until June 2009 nearly a full year after Helen had disappeared. The only thing of interest they found out in the water was a nine-layer bucket filled with concrete embedded in the concrete at the top was a small wire loop and a length of synthetic rope was attached. Adam admitted that it was his bucket. The coroner said he couldn't draw any conclusions from the bucket. It was found in a location which meant it was
搜寻范围在第二个月扩大了。动用了直升机、潜水员和地面搜救队。尽管进行了广泛的搜寻，但始终没有找到海伦的任何踪迹。关于亚当在海伦失踪当晚使用船只的行踪的信息直到很久以后才为人所知，而对海伦失踪近一年后的2009年6月，警方才对她家外面的海域进行了搜寻。他们在水里发现的唯一引起兴趣的东西是一个九层的桶，里面灌满了水泥，水泥顶部嵌入了一个小钢丝圈，并连接了一段合成绳。亚当承认那是他的桶。验尸官表示，他无法从这个桶中得出任何结论。它被发现的地点意味着在
covered by only about half a meter of water at low tide. Adam said the bucket was there as he used it to secure the boat at times. However police divers have said that it was found in an area where it would not have had a purpose for being a boat mooring. The rope was tested for human fibres but none were found but given it had been in the ocean for nearly a year if there was anything to find it could have been washed away long ago. Likewise if there was any other evidence to find out there that too could have been washed away long ago. It was almost one year after Helen's disappearance that the search was done and the Bass Strait Ocean is notoriously rough and known for strong currents. The boat was forensically tested but that also returned no result.
退潮时只被大约半米深的水覆盖。亚当说这个桶在那里是因为他有时用它来固定船只。然而，警方潜水员表示，它被发现的区域根本没有作为系船栓的用途。绳子接受了人类纤维检测，但没有发现任何纤维；鉴于它在海里泡了将近一年，如果有什么可发现的，可能早就被冲走了。同样，如果外面还有其他证据，也可能早就被冲走了。搜寻工作是在海伦失踪近一年后进行的，而且巴斯海峡的海域历来波涛汹涌，以强流著称。该船也接受了法医检测，但同样没有得出任何结果。
There is no evidence that Helen Munning's made contact with anyone after being dropped off by Adam Taylor about 6 p.m. the 23rd of July 2008. Adam is the last known person to see her alive. There is no evidence to tell us what happened to Helen exactly but there are only a few possibilities. The first being that she ran away and is still alive and living somewhere else. This was the scenario presented by Adam at the coronial inquest. Helen was young and had lived her entire life in Bernie. All her friends were in Bernie and most of her family. She had limited education, limited income and no savings. She left her purse and all of her cards at home. She didn't take any clothing or personal belongings with her at all.
没有证据表明海伦·曼宁斯在2008年7月23日傍晚6点左右被亚当·泰勒放下车后与任何人有过接触。亚当是已知最后一个看到她活着的人。没有证据告诉我们海伦究竟发生了什么，但只有几种可能性。第一种是她离家出走，目前仍然活着并住在其他地方。这是亚当在验尸聆讯中提出的设想。海伦很年轻，一生都在伯尔尼度过。她所有的朋友和大部分家人都在伯尔尼。她受教育程度有限，收入有限，也没有积蓄。她把钱包和所有的卡都留在了家里。她没有带走任何衣物或个人物品。
She had never mentioned to anyone about ever wanting to leave or to run away. Extensive checks were conducted around the country and there is no record of her showing up anywhere. Her bank accounts haven't been accessed since the day she disappeared. Plus Helen was pregnant at the time. She would have required some kind of medical treatment and there is no record of that ever happening. Not to mention it would also mean she would have had to have abandoned her son Tom whom she was extremely devoted to. Helen didn't run away and the coroner actually rejected the suggestion that she ran away. The possibility that Helen may have committed suicide was also raised.
她从未向任何人提起过想要离开或出走。警方在全国范围内进行了广泛的排查，没有她出现在任何地方的记录。自她失踪那天起，她的银行账户就再也没有被访问过。此外，海伦当时怀有身孕。她需要某种医疗护理，但没有这方面的记录。更不用说，这意味着她必须抛弃她极为疼爱的儿子汤姆。海伦没有离家出走，验尸官实际上驳回了她离家出走的说法。海伦可能自杀的可能性也被提出。
Although there was some evidence that Helen had spoken about or sent some text messages to friends about suicide it was only in a very general and conversational way. There is no evidence at all that she had ever made an attempt or a serious threat of suicide. And again it would mean abandoning Tom. Although Helen had at times been down before there was evidence that she was actively making plans for her future. Suicide doesn't seem to make a lot of sense especially considering her body still hasn't been found which is unusual for cases of suicide. Also she would have had very limited means to commit suicide. She had nothing with her to harm herself with. The coroner though didn't rule it out entirely. He said it remains a possibility and the fact her body was never found
尽管有一些证据表明海伦曾向朋友谈到过或发送过关于自杀的短信，但这仅限于非常笼统和随意的交流。没有任何证据表明她曾有过自杀企图或认真的自杀威胁。同样，这也意味着要抛弃汤姆。尽管海伦有时情绪低落，但有证据表明她正在积极为自己的未来做计划。自杀似乎说不通，特别是考虑到她的尸体至今仍未被找到，这在自杀案件中很不寻常。此外，她自杀的手段非常有限。她身上没有任何可以伤害自己的东西。不过，验尸官并没有完全排除这种可能性。他说这仍然是一种可能性，而且她的尸体从未被找到这一事实
would be unusual if it was a case of suicide but it didn't remove the possibility entirely. One example the coroner cited would be that if Helen had swum out into the ocean so far that she couldn't return. But most believe Helen was murdered. There is no direct evidence to suggest another person is responsible for Helen's death. There is no direct evidence toying anyone to Helen's disappearance including Adam Taylor. Having said that there's also no evidence to corroborate Adam Taylor's version of what happened that afternoon we just have his word for it. The coroner found he wasn't telling the truth about his account of the nature of his relationship with Helen. Adam was trying to say it had finished and he wasn't seeing her any longer
如果是自杀案件会很不寻常，但这并没有完全消除这种可能性。验尸官举的一个例子是，如果海伦游进海里太远而无法返回。但大多数人相信海伦被谋杀。没有直接证据表明其他人对海伦的死负有责任。没有直接证据将任何人与海伦的失踪联系起来，包括亚当·泰勒。话虽如此，也没有证据来证实亚当·泰勒关于那天下午发生的事情的说法，我们只有他的一面之词。验尸官发现，他关于自己与海伦关系性质的说法并未说实话。亚当试图说这段感情已经结束，他不再见她了
but text messages found between them painted a very different picture. In fact he took active steps to conceal his relationship with Helen from Carolina and his mother. Helen's disappearance coincided with a time that Adam was trying to preserve his relationship with Carolina in circumstances that had been difficult for some time. The fact Helen was pregnant again would have impacted Adam in a number of ways. The obvious one would be the increased strain that it would put on his already strained relationship with Carolina. There are also concerns whether the journey he described to police would have taken the one hour and 40 minutes he says he was with Helen and his story of the route they
但他们之间被发现的短信却描绘了一幅截然不同的画面。事实上，他积极采取措施，对卡罗琳娜和母亲隐瞒他与海伦的关系。海伦的失踪恰逢亚当试图在长期以来一直很艰难的情况下维护与卡罗琳娜的关系。海伦再次怀孕的事实会以多种方式对亚当产生影响。最明显的一点是，这会给本已紧张的与卡罗琳娜的关系增添更大的压力。人们还担心，他向警方描述的行程是否真的需要他所说的那一个小时四十分钟，并且他和海伦
took during their drive changed. He gave two different versions of where exactly they went. The coroner commented that just because Adam had been untruthful about the extent of his relationship with Helen it didn't mean he was lying about his account of what happened that afternoon. Likewise the coroner said no conclusions could be made from the inconsistencies in his account of where exactly they drove to that afternoon and what way they went. The behavior with the boat was interesting but the coroner ruled Adam's version wasn't far-fetched and could quite likely be true. Carol and Helen's grandmother visited Adam a few days after Helen's disappearance.
在驾车途中所走路线的说法前后不一。他给出了关于他们到底去了哪里的两个不同版本。验尸官评论说，仅仅因为亚当在与海伦关系的程度上不诚实，并不意味着他在那天下午发生的事情的叙述上在说谎。同样，验尸官表示，无法从他对那天下午具体开车去了哪里以及走哪条路的陈述中的矛盾之处得出任何结论。他对船只的行为很有意思，但验尸官裁定亚当的说法并非异想天开，很有可能是真的。卡罗尔和海伦的祖母在海伦失踪几天后拜访了亚当。
Her grandmother alleges Adam made a statement to her which indicated he knew Helen was never coming back. Adam denies this happened. Carol claims that in October 2009 she approached Adam in a supermarket and asked him where Helen's body was. She alleges that Adam threatened her saying you'll get the same done to you that Helen did. Adam of course strongly denies ever saying that. The coroner had significant reservations about how true Carol and Helen's grandmother's allegations are given the amount of ill will Carol and the grandmother have towards Adam. The coroner doubted these comments were ever made. Effectively he was saying he believes Carol and Helen's grandmother made it up and he went on to say even if Adam had made these comments he
她的祖母声称亚当对她发表了一番言论，表明他知道海伦永远不会回来了。亚当否认此事发生过。卡罗尔声称，在2009年10月，她在一家超市接近亚当，并质问他海伦的尸体在哪里。她声称亚当威胁她，说：“海伦落得什么下场，你也会落得什么下场。”亚当当然强烈否认说过这样的话。鉴于卡罗尔和祖母对亚当怀有极大的敌意，验尸官对卡罗尔和海伦祖母的指控是否属实保留了重大异议。验尸官怀疑这些言论从未被发表过。实际上，他是在说他相信卡罗尔和海伦的祖母是捏造的，他接着说，即使亚当真的发表过这些言论，他
wouldn't regard either statement as an admission of guilt. The coronial inquest was held over nine separate days between the 29th of November 2011 and the 12th of January 2012. On the 14th of June 2012, coroner Robert Pierce made his official ruling. The coroner's found missing Bernie woman Helen Munnings is dead but he hasn't been able to say how she died. Her family maintains she was murdered and is seeking further legal advice on the case. Selena Bryan reports. 20-year-old Helen Munnings disappeared four years ago. Her body has never been found despite years of searching. Over nine days the coroner Robert Pierce heard evidence from more than 40 witnesses. Today he handed down his finding saying Helen Munnings died on or about the 23rd of July 2008 most likely in or around Bernie.
也不会将这两项陈述中的任何一项视为认罪。验尸聆讯于2011年11月29日至2012年1月12日之间的九个不同日子里举行。2012年6月14日，验尸官罗伯特·皮尔斯（Robert Pearce）作出了官方裁决。验尸官裁定失踪的伯尔尼女子海伦·曼宁斯已经死亡，但他无法说明她是如何死亡的。她的家人坚称她被谋杀，并正在就此案寻求进一步的法律咨询。塞琳娜·布莱恩（Selena Bryan）报道。20岁的海伦·曼宁斯于四年前失踪。尽管经过多年的搜寻，她的尸体仍未被找到。在九天的时间里，验尸官罗伯特·皮尔斯听取了40多名证人的证词。今天他下达了裁决，称海伦·曼宁斯于2008年7月23日左右死亡，最有可能在伯尔尼或其周边地区。
But the coroner said the evidence doesn't enable a finding of how her death occurred or the cause. The coroner said there was a possibility Ms Munnings took her own life but that was reduced because of her love for her young son. Ms Munnings was last seen going for a drive with Adam Taylor, the father of the boy. The coroner found it was likely that at the time of her disappearance Helen Munnings was pregnant and likely that Adam Taylor was the father. The council assisting told the inquest Mr Taylor had the motive and opportunity to kill Ms Munnings. Her mother hopes the findings allow police to further investigate how her daughter died. We're pretty pleased that it's acknowledged that Helen is dead and hoping that it gives the CIB more clout. The coroner said there
但验尸官表示，现有证据无法裁定她的死亡是如何发生的或具体死因。验尸官表示，曼宁斯女士有可能是自杀身亡，但由于她对年幼儿子的爱，这种可能性有所降低。曼宁斯女士最后一次露面是和该男孩的父亲亚当·泰勒一起去兜风。验尸官裁定，在海伦·曼宁斯失踪时，她很可能已经怀孕，且亚当·泰勒极有可能是孩子的父亲。协助调查的法律顾问在聆讯中表示，泰勒先生有杀害曼宁斯女士的动机和机会。她的母亲希望这些裁决能让警方进一步调查她女儿的死因。“我们很高兴人们承认海伦已经死了，并希望这能给CIB（刑事调查局）带来更多影响力。”验尸官说，
was no scientific or forensic evidence to find Mr Taylor contributed to the death. He said he found fanciful a suggestion by Mr Taylor's council that Ms Munnings is alive in Darwin. Her mother says she's seeking legal advice on what she believes was a police conflict of interest when the investigation began. I'm claiming that the case wasn't dealt with properly at the beginning because of the conflict. Police say the investigation has been reviewed several times with no adverse findings. The investigation into Helen Munnings death remains active and ongoing. Police still want to speak to anyone with information about how the young woman died. Selina Bryan, ABC News, Bernie. The case is still open. There is currently a $100,000 reward for any information regarding Helen's disappearance. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没有科学或法医证据表明泰勒先生导致了她的死亡。他说，泰勒先生的律师提出曼宁斯女士还活在达尔文（Darwin）的说法是异想天开。她的母亲表示，她正在就调查开始时她认为存在的警方利益冲突寻求法律咨询。“我声称由于利益冲突，案件在一开始就没有得到妥善处理。”警方表示，该调查已进行了多次复核，未发现不利结果。对海伦·曼宁斯死因的调查仍然活跃且正在进行中。警方仍然希望与任何掌握这名年轻女子死因信息的知情者交谈。澳大利亚广播公司新闻（ABC News）伯尔尼记者塞琳娜·布莱恩报道。此案仍然悬而未决。目前对任何有关海伦失踪的信息悬赏10万元。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。